effectivement Roland Lescure cette
première réquisition d'un centre de
dépôt de carburant est-ce que ça n'a pas
jeter de l'huile sur le feu dans les
négociations entre syndicats et
direction de Total et des sceaux c'est
pas moi qui l'ai dit c'est Maurice
Thorez un moment faut savoir arrêter une
grève il y a eu du dialogue communiste
oui il y a eu du dialogue social il y a
eu des négociations il y a eu un accord
en tout cas pour ce qui est des
raffineries des sauts ah d'accord
majoritaire par ailleurs il est logique
que les gens reprennent le travail après
la signature d'un arrêt majoritaire n'en
déplaise à deux syndicats qui
aujourd'hui sont minoritaires donc le
gouvernement d'abord fait sa part du
travail prend sa part de responsabilité
et surtout en temps en cela je pense
l'immense majorité des Français des
Français qui considèrent certes que le
dialogue social c'est bien mais que ça
doit pas se transformer en blocage
antisocial pas de blocage en tout cas du
côté de la droite on est assez critique
aussi sur la réaction du gouvernement
qui est jugée trop tardive insuffisante
pour l'instant c'est juste un centre de
dépôt qui est réquisitionné et est-ce
que ça va vraiment et bien soulager le
blocage actuel que vous répondez à ces
critiques on répond qu'on a laissé le
dialogue social se faire et que si ça
n'avait pas été le cas on ne l'aurait
peut-être aussi reproché donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut trouver un équilibre laissez
le temps en temps on est dans une
période difficile où les négociations
salariales sont finalement nécessaires
un peu partout pas seulement dans les
raffineries elles ont besoin de se tenir
après il faut que chacun prenne ses
restes responsabilités les oppositions
le gouvernement la majorité et les
syndicats y compris ce minoritaires ça
c'est important je pense est-ce que vous
pourrez aller sur d'autres réquisitions
pour vraiment soulager ce blocage des
stations services il est évident qu'on
suit la situation j'allais dire heure
par heure et qu'on adaptera la réponse
du gouvernement au comportement des uns
des autres et qu'on fera tout pour que
les Français et les Français aient accès
à adolescence pour aller travailler pour
aller soigner pour vivre tout simplement
dernière question sur le sujet que vous
avez évoqué durant cette séance cet
après-midi les entreprises notre
industrie face à la crise de l'énergie
avec certaines entreprises qui sont
obligées de fermer et de mettre la clé
sous la porte temporairement car elles
ne peuvent pas payer leur facture
énergie et ce qu'il y a un soutien
financier de l'État sur ces entreprises
qui sont obligées de fermer bien sûr ça
fait 5 ans qu'on réindustrialise la
France on va pas laisser la crise en
Ukraine nous désindustrialisés donc on
soutient les entreprises françaises et
surtout on augmente le soutien on le
rend plus souple flexible on le prolonge
tout ça se fait dans le cas de
négociation européenne qui sont
extrêmement ambitieuses qui vont je
pense déboucher comme toujours en Europe
à minuit moins 5 à la dernière minute
dans les jours qui viennent il y a un
sommaire européen les 20 et 21 octobre
prochain on travaille fort pour que
d'ici là on puisse soulager nos
entreprises il est hors de question que
l'entreprise l'industrie française soit
la victime collatérale du conflit en
Ukraine merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'avoir répondu aux questions depuis que
c'est non
[Musique]